thanks jillian finley acura the sponsor
of this next segment is spreading the
word about how the community can help
our kids have more access to the books
they need and love here's how you can
get involved
my name is travis aguilar we're here at
the valley's best kept secret finley
acura and today we wanted to continue to
do
our community outreach family acura has
been big in the community along with the
finley's for many years whether it's
from
giving away turkey dinners around the
holiday season
or
spreading the word for some of our
other
organizations like spread the word
nevada as we're getting into back to
school season
we thought it's something that's really
important just to help develop some of
our young leaders and readings key with
that so that's why we wanted to team up
here with spread the word we do have uh
lisa habbaghorst here today to give us
some more detail into what they're all
about here spread the word nevada is so
excited to partner with finley acura on
this book drive
books are needed more than ever in our
valley our kids have been suffering for
the last year by staying at home they've
lost a lot of learning especially the
children we serve
they don't have a lot of resources in
their home to help their education
so the more that we can get back and get
these books into the homes to help these
kids look forward to a brighter future
by reading by exploring by learning
about different cultures that's what
we're all about is helping these
children spread the word nevada started
20 years ago as a very small community
give back project that we never knew
would grow to the size it is currently
we're in 65 schools across the state and
in our rural areas with boys and girls
clubs partnering
what we do is we put books into the
hands of children who can't afford them
we train families the importance about
reading together as a family and what
they can do to help their children's
education
we also have a mentoring program where
volunteers work one-on-one with
struggling readers
and then we also have a summer reading
program all together those programs have
served over right around 700 000 kids
across our state for these past 20 years
with about 7 million books
so we're very excited about what we do
every month we give out about 60 000
books so we really encourage and employ
you to bring in your books here at
findlay acura what we mostly need is
preschool through fifth grade but our
hardest is the fourth and fifth grade
chapter books that captain underpants
and the magic treehouse that we used to
read with our families those are the
ones our kids love
but we'll take any books preschool
through fifth grade so that we can get
them into the hands of those families
who need them and while you're here if
you are in the market
for a vehicle or looking to just sell
your vehicle we are in the market for
pre-owned vehicles so we're given top
dollar on vehicles whether you trade it
in or not swing by let us give you a
professional appraisal
thank you finley acura for sponsoring
this segment if you'd like to drop off
books they're located on auto mall drive
in henderson for more information call
702-982-4100
or visit
findlayacura.com we'll be right back